y en nuestra sección de salud hoy nos
acompaña mar Romero para hablar de un
tema que tiene que ver directamente con
las mujeres mar bienvenida cómo está muy
bien clamaria Clara y tú muy bien
empecemos con una propuesta que rechazó
el parlamento británico de dar Las bajas
laborales a las personas durante la
menopausia Sí ayer estábamos hablando de
Las bajas por el período menstrual ahora
vamos a hablar de Las bajas por la
menopausia básicamente es lo mismo No
que las mujeres y las personas que
estaban menstruando puedan pedirse la
baja laboral cuando los síntomas de la
menopausia son agudos no según un
estudio británico de fauces society hay
una de cada 10 mujeres en Reino Unido
que ha tenido que dejar su trabajo a
raíz de estos síntomas que vienen con
este proceso fisiológico que además es
un tema que no está muy estudiado no
está sobre todo muy hablado ni
normalizado en nuestras sociedades
además los síntomas pueden llegar entre
los 45-55 años Aunque puede ser antes o
después que puede ser un momento en la
vida laboral de las mujeres a las que
podrían acceder a más posiciones de
poder dentro de sus trabajos Aunque
sobre todo esto recae también en las
mujeres más precarizadas que podrían
tener eso como decíamos problemas pues
para dejar de ir a trabajar porque
dejarían de cobrar el día o también el
riesgo de ser despedidas al no rendir de
la misma forma en el trabajo escuchamos
un testimonio
realmente impactó mi trabajo tenía miedo
de estar desarrollando demencia temprana
iba a las reuniones y a veces no podía
ni recordar por qué había entrado en una
habitación revisaba presupuestos o temas
de trabajo y me sentía abrumada
usted mencionaba que los síntomas
comienzan más o menos a los 45 años pero
cuáles son esos síntomas y qué pasa en
la menopausia pues se considera
menopausia cuando hay ya 12 meses
seguidos sin periodo aunque los síntomas
pueden empezar desde antes en un periodo
que se llama perimenopausia no es
básicamente el fin de la vida
reproductiva de una mujer Y eso implica
una cantidad de cambios hormonales sobre
todo de como el estrógeno o la
progesterona que son las hormonas
sexuales femeninas pero que también
tienen muchísimo peso en otros procesos
del cuerpo algunos de los síntomas los
calores súbitos o focos que quizás son
los más conocidos pero también hay
problemas de insomnio y para dormir
estamos hablando incluso de problemas
urinarios como la incontinencia
problemas vaginales por ejemplo más
propensión a las infecciones pero es que
incluso también problemas de
concentración de memoria hasta dos
tercios en Reino Unido reportaba este
tipo de problemas además de un impacto
en la Salud Mental con más propensión a
periodos de ansiedad o depresión por
supuesto la gravedad de estos síntomas
varía o la cantidad de síntomas varía de
persona a persona no para todo el mundo
es un proceso traumático ni mucho menos
pero es un cambio corporal muy
importante para las mujeres que pasan
sin ningún tipo de acompañamiento y con
muy poca investigación apenas tenemos
datos por ejemplo de Por qué suceden
algunos de estos síntomas relacionados
con la menopausia bueno Y ahora sí le
propongo que pasemos a noticias más
positivas porque puede haber una segunda
enfermedad erradicada en el mundo de qué
se trata la primera fue la viruela Esta
es una enfermedad parasitaria se llama
gusano de Guinea o dracunculosis no y
empieza sobre todo al tomar agua
infectada por este parásito la persona
se infecta y después entre 10 y 14 meses
ha estado desarrollando un gusano que
tiene que salir después de su cuerpo por
una herida es muy desagradable es
doloroso no suele ser mortal Pero puede
ser totalmente incapacitante Además
porque como vemos es un proceso bastante
largo afecta comunidades rurales sin
acceso agua potable muchas veces y
además no tiene vacuna no tiene
tratamientos simplemente sería
erradicada en este caso si se consigue
Pues con medidas de saneamientos de
prevención de agua de acceso a medidas
de higiene bueno y que tantos casos ha
habido esta enfermedad Pues en 2022
llegaron las cifras ayer se detectaron
solo 13 casos en todo el mundo y esto
decía Carter Center uno de sus
representantes que es una de las ongs
Pues que encabeza este proceso
es un gran logro reportar solo 13
infecciones es un descenso increíble
desde 3,5 millones pero la última milla
es la más difícil
son casos que suceden en comunidades con
un acceso muy difícil sin acceso a agua
potable o a infraestructuras de salud
básicas
mencionaban estos a 3 millones y medio
de personas que en la década de los 80
tenía esta enfermedad anualmente era
endémica además en 20 países
mayoritariamente del continente africano
pero también en Asia vemos que la caída
ha sido muy significativa en 2012 más de
500 casos a partir de 2020 ya en cifras
de dos dígitos y como decíamos 2022 solo
13 casos actualmente los países en los
que se han detectado son chats del sur
Etiopía y República centroafricana Bueno
una enfermedad impresionante como usted
nos contaba pero pasar tres coma cinco
millones a Trece casos Si es una gran
noticia es todo un logro es todo un
logro Gracias mar por la información de
salud nos vemos mañana nos vemos